i like i almost died during covey i
caught covert
and um
that's just a wake-up call like go off
your drink i don't wanna die old man
full of regrets
did you have any businesses before you
started your production company no
first business ever
so you were always an employee
yeah i was managing before at
security
i was working in hr department
supervisor so i always was employee yeah
how did you start your production
company well my first movie um i wanted
to brand myself i learned from tyler
perry um by brandon stuff he had todd
perfect films or studios whatever at the
time and i said we do answer all the
films and i first i went to legal zone
legalzoom is a website that you could
basically trademark your company
do everything for your company to get
your kit up and running at llcc and go
through them it's way cheaper than uh
going to a lawyer
legalzoom.com
so you got you did your sort of articles
of incorporation or your i'm not sure if
that's for llc or not yeah okay
and then you
trade so i did so
i did llcc that's for tax purposes so
you do all that whether state you win
you do that
and then the second thing you want to do
is trademark your name
because even though answer allen is my
name i said the trade market you gotta
do two trademarks you do the name
trademark you do the logo draymond and
you do step-by-step baby steps but you
want to get that you went to llcc get a
bank account and then you want to
trademark your name
and why an llc i mean it could be
whatever you want i did the llc because
that's that's it works with me okay so
that an llc is its own structure then
it's it's so it's if you do llcc or you
do incorporation okay yeah so whatever
makes sense for you but you want to do
that first and then your bank account
and they want to trademark your name
what about for tax purposes what are you
doing same thing uh you we with attack
purposes if you're making money you know
you want to get an accountant
for it but legalzoom i think they help
you with that you can get accountable if
you go to legalzoom.com all that
information there that gets you up and
running
and then what was the first thing you
spent money on aside from legalzoom
because i'm assuming legals didn't cost
yeah yeah so legal zone first and then
your project your film project
whoever the firm project is and what you
want to do too that i'll learn later on
when you do a film such as feature films
you want to get a bank account just for
that film so this instead of you doing
your projection company so if your film
is lola you want your bank account say
lola do a llcc just for that bank
account what that does is that
protective that protects you and
protects the film so all the money is
going through the llcc for the movie not
for the production company so if you get
an investor hey i want to invest in your
movie write the check to lola llcc and
stuff like that you want to separate the
money
yeah
what was the first piece of equipment
you bought i don't buy equipment i have
no equipment so what i do is i hire a
cinematographer to hire a crew to do my
projects i have no equipment
no costumes
no i don't buy anything i just hired a
crew i just hired a dp production
company key grip i would hire a whole
team
and do my movie so you had the llc you
had the trademark
you had the bank account
and then you started
looking on film so
it films up
so so you had already started shooting
at this point or you waited to make sure
all the ducks were in a row no sometimes
i did it sometimes i made decks in a row
i weighed it
the little depends
can't do everything right the first time
but yeah but after a while you know you
get it structured to get it together so
you don't have to you could start off
without doing any of that stuff but when
money start coming in you start getting
big checks you want to have that because
when the investor writes you a check
they're not writing to your name they're
going right to the production company so
when you get to that point you want to
get all that together so you don't have
to do it right away it's no rush
did you take out any loans
no
everything all my money i ever started
it came from
uh if i needed extra funds friends and
family
or an investor but majority money came
for my 9 to 5 job
yep
so then you would shoot on the weekends
no sometimes you have to work
oh i had a job always have vacation so i
might use my vacation time
to shoot and stuff like that
i look like i have a good support system
like i'm married
and having a great wife a great partner
is the best thing because you know when
you're out on set and having that
partner at home so
shout out to my wife soraya okay
very nice and is she a filmmaker too no
she's in a whole different world she's
in real estate and that's nothing to i'd
rather they be with someone or marry
someone that's out of my field
this great why is that too too
complicated um it's two different worlds
i dated someone before before my wife
and there was an actress and
they wanna be in your movies and all
this stuff like
go go make your own movie
yeah but yeah it's a great thing yeah
marvel's great so so it's kind of
compliments one another when two people
are different yeah it does they want
different ones in different worlds so
like my wife she's amazing so
um having like having that partnership
and building your foundation is very
important
so
the way y'all watching this wait don't
settle for less
how many people were involved with the
production company when you started and
then now when i first started
maybe five six people i got rid of all
of them
and now just me and two other people but
really like i said me i'm the
i'm the captain ship but i have people i
work with like two three people i got my
partner eugene
i work with another guy john taurus um
i'm on the partner i work with i'm
working with now lester green so i have
different parties they and change in and
out well they're also writing these
scripts
do you advise people to just start small
and don't hire a bunch of people yeah
start small
a lot of times
we want to look outside a house
and the people you need right in your
house
it's like stop eating out it's
homecoming fooling house what basically
means don't try to search for the big
names like yo you have talent right in
your backyard
so you have friends and family build
that team build your crew up you don't
have to go out and try to build someone
else out like everything is in your
house you just got to look for the right
people in your backyard
what are your duties your day-to-day
duties with the production company so
right now
is writing projects pitching projects
getting funded for it
before i had before covet i was still
working by 9-5 but now i no longer i do
this full time now i'm not been doing
the foot time but i'm completely flip
time now
why why did kovid um if you don't mind
me asking take you out of the full-time
job the nine to five because it gave me
i mean i was i was out a year before
coverage oh okay i was supposed to go
back
but i decided not to go back and cover
taught me that life is too short
no one promised them all
why are you working at that job that you
hate
i like i almost died during kofi i
covered
and um
that's just a wake-up call like go out
for your drink i don't want to die old
man full of regrets
did it really knock you out yeah was it
almost died i was out of here oh wow
because i had diabetes i'm type 1
diabetes
i did a podcast with y'all guys and i
talked about
the last video i did with you guys i
talked about my diabetes while i'm doing
part one i almost died i always take
care of myself so this time around court
cove with the diabetes and it was a bad
match but i survived it
mass did you have any long-term effects
yes
my back ache a lot it went away but i
had like back problems so wow
i thought i was pregnant my back was
hurting and stuff everything but it was
it was um it was a bad lot of back pains
i don't know why is that part of the
side effects i guess so i had a lot of i
was taking a while to get rid of my back
pains wow same thing my wife my wife
caught it
and she really had no substance about
the back pains
so i was in the hospital and she she was
fine she just had back pains but we both
made it through
so knowing that you caught it and you're
so young
and you have so much you want you were
just like you know what
i don't this isn't worth it to me yeah
because you know sometimes little life
like a rehearsal
and it's not worth it like it's not
worth to be unhappy
so you know betting yourself i could
always get a job
but i said no way i'm not going back i
was going to go back to work but i see
him like now let me better myself and
then the bet work
so cover the wake-up call man like you
know i know it's hard out there but
you got to always choose you first
and was lola 2 already set in motion
no those who was a blessing because i
was going to do those too
i was going to wait because
i had no money
but god gave me a blessing monica floyd
she said answer i believe in you
and she believes in me to get a film for
me and now we're inseparable
the best business partner i've ever had